Let's go next to Niki from Germany.
Niki from Germany.
What's going on?
Hello, David.
Yes.
Can you listen?
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
Oh, that's fine.
First, I want to thank you for all the life
streaming you do.
My pleasure.
Yes, it's amazing what they're happening in
the US and we are terrified.
Absolutely.
Yes.
I just cat.
If Trump wins, I'm scared for your safety
or.
I have a feeling they will go to the to prosecute
the last.
I worry about the same thing, Nicky, and in
fact, earlier this week on the bonus show
I'm sorry, in the voicemail segment of a viewer
called in and asked what preparations are
being made and without getting into a lot
of detail.
We have established duplicate studios.
They look exactly the same, but they are in
various bunkers, in different parts of the
United States such that we would be able to
retreat to other studios if it became necessary.
There are actually some progressive hosts
who they they don't even live where they pop.
Like if you look at their Wikipedia pages
and their Facebook profiles, it says they
live in one place.
They really live somewhere completely different.
So there's a lot going on behind the scenes.
Nikki, from this from the standpoint of sassy,
I can understand.
It's just so I don't have what's right.
Yeah.
Now, let me ask you this story from Germany.
Do you see the U.S.?
And do you pity us?
Do you laugh at us?
What is the primary emotion?
I feel sorry.
I really feel sorry for all the people who
might lose their health insurance and who
can't pay their rent.
Yeah, it's terrible, really.
I just feel sorry.
And I'm not laughing about the US.
I laugh at Trump.
Yes.
Yeah.
A laughing stock.
But it's also very dangerous, right?
So we have to system it was settled.
And it's just so much the same.
And it's terrifying.
I thought this would never happen again.
Well, people just don't know.
Well, Nikki, let's hope for the best best
and check in after the election, OK?
Yes.
All right.
I wish you all the best.
Good luck.
Thank you, Nick.
There is Nikki from Germany.
Hope to be back in Germany very, very soon.
It would be it would be great to do it.
Let's go to Mackenzie Mackenzie from Mackenzie
from CITs.
Cut off Mackenzie from somewhere.
Hold on a second.
Mackenzie, you are unmuted Mackenzie from
Catoosa, California.
McKenzie is self muted.
All right, I'm going to have to turn the mute
back on that failed.
That did not work.